merci albert et le président mitterrand
était aujourd'hui dans la nièvre dans
l'allier et dans le puy de dôme il
s'agissait de fêter dignement les 200
ans de la création des départements le
président a parlé des problèmes
régionaux et aussi de décentralisation
mais il a aussi parlé des affaires
politiques en cours jean-michel mercurol
confidences dans un train du président
entre moulins et clermont ferrand mais
françois mitterrand ne dira rien de plus
ni sur le congrès de rennes 10 sur le
candidat aux présidentielles
rien de plus mais il ne dément pas non
plus les propos qu'on lui prête dans la
presse ce matin c'est que le président
veut se consacrer au département à la
décentralisation sujet aride mais qu'il
faut traiter dit il il y va de la
démocratie locale et de l'organisation
du pays les régions sont trop nombreuses
trop petit il faut les redimensionner
pour les mettre à la mesure du grand
marché européen autre message restituer
aux citoyens tout leur pouvoir là où la
décentralisation abouti à créer des p o
déliter locales et au passage d'inciter
le gouvernement à aller plus vite dans
la chasse au cumul des mandats
s'il est juste nécessaire que les élus
soient indemnisés pour le temps qu'ils
prélèvent sur leur activité
professionnelle il faut aussi éviter
qu'un exercice et le cumul des mandats
électifs procure à ceux qui les
détiennent dr revenus sans rapport avec
le temps qu'ils y consacrent une journée
bilan à l'occasion du bicentenaire du
département françois mitterrand veut
poursuivre et améliorer l'oeuvre de la
décentralisation nul doute que s'il
s'était risqué sur le commentaire des
divisions entre socialistes il y aurait
eu plus de chance d'être entendu